there are 26 days until election day
you will be the ultimate jury buckle up
brace yourself
this will be a roller coaster ride the
next 26 days
now during last night's debate vice
president mike pence was
unflappable and he not only eviscerated
frankly senator kamala harris but he
exposed
just how radical and frankly dangerous
her
and joe biden's positions truly are to
this country
she also got caught in one lie after
another her rambling her disorganized
answers
the times were even hard to watch
frankly it's hard to believe
she was ever a prosecutor given her
utter lack of preparation and terrible
execution
well more importantly by the way to date
senator harris and her frail weak
running mate the ever forgetful joe
biden
they still are flat out refusing to
answer
significant serious questions dozens of
them
including whether or not they plan
to neuter the united states supreme
court
with a corrupt practice known as court
packing
frankly it is unconscionable that they
refuse to tell you the american people
the truth
i guess they must think that we the
american people are really that stupid
they really think that they can just
coast to the finish line
without being honest without being
transparent without being forthright
of course the media mob state-run tv
news state-run newspapers
so far they've allowed them to get away
with all of this
which would be the biggest power grab in
history
and by the way that is exactly what will
happen
their non-answers as vice president
pence said
that's their answer now coming up we
have full reaction dan bongino karl rove
congressman matt gates the great one
mark levin
will be here with their full reaction
and analysis and don't forget the
president will join us straight ahead
but first we do need to talk about the
commission on presidential debates
now supposedly non-profit well
supposedly nonpartisan an organization
responsible for carrying out the
presidential and vice presidential
debates but today the commission
unilaterally
without consulting either campaign
decided to
upend the next matchup between president
trump and former vice president biden
now they were citing the president's
covet 19 diagnosis
and the commission announced that the
debate would be held out
virtually out of quote safety concerns
the problem is that was a unilateral
decision
they did not consult with the
president's doctors they didn't consult
with any doctor that we know of
or the trump campaign or the president
himself
and by the way by october the 15th the
president will be more than 14 days away
from when he first contracted covet 19
which means he will no longer according
to our own cdc be shedding the virus
and we'll likely have immunity and i'm
sure our doctors will be checking that
out in the first place
so what's really going on here is it
really about covert 19 or is this debate
commission
trying to basically harness president
trump and help joe biden earlier today
donald trump jr tweeted the following
does anyone else find it
awfully coincidental that this the
morning after mike pence destroys kamala
harris in a debate
that the debate commission unilaterally
changes the format
to obviously benefit basement biden now
keep in mind during a virtual format the
moderators
well they'd have access to a mute button
and sleepy joe would have easy access to
his trusty teleprompter
so today during an interview with our
colleague and friend maria bartiromo the
president
announced that he will not participate
in this virtual debate
and this last minute rule change and the
president's right
it's time that we now ask the important
question here
is the commission on presidential
debates in the tank for joe biden
has this turned into an anti-trump
organization
i think the evidence and the answer is
sadly all too obvious the moderator of
the second presidential debate
if it happens is a guy by the name of
steven scully
i actually know him met him actually
like him he interned for joe biden he
worked for senator ted kennedy
was that a factor in the debate
commission's decision and meanwhile last
night's vice presidential debate
moderator susan page
well currently is writing a seemingly
glowing biography of
nancy pelosi entitled quote madam
speaker nancy pelosi in the lessons of
power
i guess it's no surprise that she failed
to ask senator harris dozens of
important questions
why i don't know she didn't ask about
law and order and safety and security
and the unrest that we've been watching
for the entire summer
she didn't ask about senator harris's
support for that bail fund in
minneapolis to put violent rioters and
anarchists back on the streets
she didn't ask well senator harris about
you know
all about calling joe biden pretty much
a racist on a democratic debate stage
she didn't ask about the time that
harris said she believed biden's sexual
harassment
and assault accusers she didn't ask
kamala harris
about her smear of justice kavanaugh she
didn't ask about zero experienced hunter
and the millions of dollars that he made
from foreign countries
while his father was the vice president
she didn't even ask about packing the
courts
in fact it was vice president mike pence
who brought up any of these issues
and when he did senator harris just flat
out refused to answer the question
an all-important power grab a
constitutional issue
something that has not been touched in
over 150 years
and he asked her over and over again and
still didn't get an answer
take a look judge amy coney barrett is
confirmed with the supreme court of the
united states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
joe and i are very clear
the american people are voting right now
and it should be their decision
about who will serve on this most
important body
for a lifetime thank you senator
harrison
susan are voting right now they'd like
to know if you and joe biden are going
to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave him
anonymous trying to answer you
american people deserve a straight
answer the non-answer is unanswered now
by the way this just breaking the
ap is reporting the chair of commission
on presidential debate says it is not
going to reconsider
shifting the second debate from virtual
back to in person despite
a request from the president and his
team now by the way
back to harris she never answered the
vice president's question
the moderator never held her accountable
didn't even follow up
so it should be no surprise that earlier
today joe biden once again
he refused to answer the question he did
say he will give us an answer
after the election take a look you'll
know my opinion of court packing when
the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking it
but you know the moment i answered that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
other than other than
focusing on what's happening now
this is a question of constitutional
magnitude
you're supposed to tell us where you
stand on the positions
to garner support of the american people
him not answering should scare every
american
and let me let you in on a secret vice
president pence was right last night
joe and kamala harris have decided
they're going to
pack the u.s supreme court as chuck
schumer said
everything's on the table now if they
get their way
and they increase the number of justices
on the supreme court
and they fill it with new activist
jurists that believe they can legislate
from the bench
people like elena kagan and sonia
sotomayor and justice breyer
well that would be corrupt it would be
illicit it would be authoritarian
it would be a maneuver to give the
democrats total control over the courts
and that which they couldn't win at the
ballot box or legislatively
it would destroy co-equal branches of
government
that would cease to exist our american
system of checks and balances would be
completely eviscerated
the media mob by the way is enabling
them to get away with not answering this
question
what else do they have in mind do they
want to end the electoral college
they want to end the legislative
filibuster do they want to make this
place or that
place or dc estate how many states do
they want to have in the union
this would be the single biggest power
grab in this country
in 150 years and it would transform this
country to its
core in a way that would not be good for
every american
and could very well destroy this
constitutional republic
it is a clear and present danger and
that's why joe and kamala harris are
keeping it a secret
but guess what you're not stopping at
court packing
they likely want to end the legislative
filibuster again
chuck schumer everything's on the table
they want to ditch the electoral college
are they ready and willing to give
washington d.c puerto rico statehood
in order to add four more guaranteed in
their minds democratic senators
in their view a guaranteed democratic
majority in the u.s senate in perpetuity
do they want one state party rule zero
rights zero
input for the minority party because
that's what it looks like
and the media mob the so-called
unpartisan debate moderators can't even
be bothered to ask a single question
about such a heavy constitutional issue
and the impact it will have on this
country
and future generations and meanwhile the
truly unhinged speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
she's just busy fantasizing still about
getting rid of president trump
she still has not accepted the results
of the 2016 election
and now says we're going to talk about
the 25th amendment
which lays out a plan of succession
should the president become
incapacitated
this is where her head is at take a look
what are we talking about here tomorrow
by the way
tomorrow come here tomorrow we're going
to be talking about the 25th amendment
but not to take attention away from the
subject we have now
do you think it's time to invoke the
25th amendment
i'll talk to you about that tomorrow
i'll talk to you about it tomorrow i'm
not talking about it today except to
tell you
if you want to talk about that we'll see
you tomorrow core packing today the 25th
amendment tomorrow what else is on the
list
pretty much a typical pelosi day just
like the last four years
this radical extreme democratic party
they care about one thing
above all else and that is power power
now over
all branches of government power over
religion
power over your health care remember
kamala harris won't even allow you to
get private insurance if she has her way
power over your businesses power over
schools power over your rights
power over every aspect of our lives and
in order to get this power
they're willing to lie deceive not be
transparent
and do everything and anything they can
do to cover up the truth about what
their real radical agenda is for example
here's senator harris blatantly lying
about joe biden's plan to raise your
taxes
remember what he said i'm going to
repeal the bush
i'm sorry the trump tax cuts that means
all of our taxes will be raised take a
look
him take he says he's smart because he
can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're going to
eliminate those taxes
the truth and the fact is joe biden has
been very clear
he will not raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than four hundred thousand a
year appeal
mr vice president i'm speaking i'm
speaking
be important if you said the truth joe
biden said twice in the debate last week
that he's going to repeal the trump tax
cuts
that was tax cuts that gave the average
working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year that senator
that is absolutely
every american that got a tax cut under
donald trump will lose it that means
their taxes will go
up senator harris also flat out lying
about fracking
and we've got the video evidence take a
look for yourself
i am not banning frackie let me say that
again
i am not banning frackie no more no no
fracking
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in the biden administration
no it would we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
and no more subsidies
for either one of those so first of all
i will repeat and the american people
know
that joe biden will not ban fracking
that is a
fact will you commit to implementing a
federal
ban on fracking your first day in office
adding the united states to the list of
countries who have banned this
devastating practice
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking so yeah
no more fracking no more fracking will
eliminate fracking but we're not
eliminating fracking
and when all else fails democrats well
they always turn to more lies about race
that happened last night with senator
harris once again accusing the president
of never condemning white supremacists
following the leader joe biden who's
been making the same false allegation
now this by the way is easily documented
as a lie also
that joe and kamala repeat over and over
and over again
and they don't care that the evidence is
proving otherwise
but to help educate them both well we
have the videotape
you ever heard this president say one
negative thing
about white supremacists have you ever
heard it
i totally disavow klux klan
i totally disavow david duke i got back
in this race because what happened in
charlottesville
people coming out of the woods carrying
torches their veins
bulging close your eyes and remember
what you saw
and a young woman gets killed resisting
the hate and violence
and the president gets asked to come in
and what's he say
he says they're very fine people on both
sides
and you had some very bad people in that
group but you also had people
that were very fine people on both sides
and i'm not talking about the neo-nazis
and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
you wouldn't even condemn david duke for
god's sake
i reject david duke rejected david duke
i've rejected the kkk the ku klux klan
from the time i'm five years old i
rejected them
26 days if these liars in the democratic
party
if they do well in the election and are
able to carry out
their stated radical agenda america the
country you know and love
it will never be the same